für die einen eine wertlose Brache für
die anderen ein umkämpftes
Investitionsobjekt denn wo ohnehin wenig
wächst lässt sich prima Energie anbauen
in ganz Brandenburg stehen
solarinvestoren Schlange bei Bauern und
Landbesitzern auch Jan Dijkstra in
tempelfelde flattern regelmäßig Angebote
ins Haus dutzender genauer Anzahl kann
ich nicht sagen aber wir kriegen noch
hoffentlich mindestens einmal in der
Woche kriegen wir einen Anfrage von ob
wir Flächen zur Verfügung stellen wollen
das Brandenburg ist einfach heiß begehrt
das Versprechen lukrative Pachtverträge
krisensichere Einkünfte und Teilhabe an
der Energiewende da extra war erst
zögerlich ließ sich aber schließlich
davon überzeugen Teile seines Ackerlands
für den Bau eines Solarparks zur
Verfügung zu stellen die Firma die mir
dann ein Angebot gemacht hat der hat von
vornherein gesagt von die waren gerne
hier etwas schräge Scheren was in höhere
Akzeptanz hat was auch von den
Bevölkerung von Vorteilen könnte und
dann fängt man an miteinander zu reden
der Tanz ist so eine Sache
Juliane Uhlig betreibt einen Pferdehof
inmitten des für das Projekt
vorgesehenen Areals seit eineinhalb
Jahren kämpft sie im Rahmen einer
Bürgerinitiative gegen den Solarpark
und wir konnten erreichen dass zumindest
Abstandsflächen jetzt eingehalten werden
sollen dass wir also nicht bis an den
Zaun ran bebaut werden aber wir reden
immer noch über 130 Hektar die hier für
diese kleine Gemeinde aus unserer Sicht
immer noch eine zu große Belastung sind
der Solarpark an sich so groß wie 186
Fußballfelder sei nicht das Problem
beteuert Ohlig seit langem hat sie
selbst eine Photovoltaikanlage auf dem
Dach was die stört die mangelnde
Bürgerbeteiligung an einem solch
landschaftspringenden Vorhaben es wäre
schön gewesen wenn die Firmen gekommen
wären und gesagt hätten Mensch wir
wollen den tempelfeld in Solarpark bauen
wir planen hier welche Flächen hat denn
tempelfelde zur Verfügung wir hätten die
Karte ausgerollt und wir hätten geguckt
welche Flächen sich dafür gut eignen zum
Beispiel vorbelastete Flächen eine alte
Mülldeponie Flächen die nicht so dicht
am Ort sind
was sind tempelfelde noch Zukunftsmusik
ist ist im benachbarten Werneuchen
längst Realität über 164 Hektar
erstreckt sich hier der aktuell größte
Solarpark Deutschlands doch die Pläne
der Investoren werden immer
ambitionierte mega Solarparks von bis zu
1.000 Hektar sollen entstehen auch auf
Ackerflächen
kritiker bezweifeln das dafür nur
ertragloses Land umgewidmet wird sorgen
sich um die Nachhaltigkeit der Pläne und
die Folgen für Mensch und Natur Ingo
Eichmann lebt mit seiner Familie in
Altlüdersdorf er liebt die Weitsicht
über die benachbarten Felder doch damit
könnte es bald vorbei sein
hier sollen Solarpark entstehen und zwar
an meinen Grundstück am drei Seiten
angrenzend
und auf der anderen Seite von der Bahn
auch
100 Meter und zwar im Vogelschutzgebiet
bzw Landschaftsschutzgebiet
gesetzlichen Vorgaben zu
Zweckentfremdung von Ackerflächen du
hast hier jedes Dorf das für sich selbst
entscheidet wo sie Flächen ausweist wo
sie den Solarpark hinmauen wollen der
eine geht hin und sagt ja 200 Meter ist
die Empfehlung wir machen 600 der
nächste geht hin und sagt wir machen 20
und wenn du blöde wohnst in genau der
Mitte bist du rund um eingebaut und eine
einheitliche staatliche Regelung für
diese Maßnahmen und die Kommunen dürfen
das nicht alleine entscheiden Simone
Krauskopf ist ehrenamtliche
Bürgermeisterin in tempelfelde sie
begrüßt die Pläne für den Solarpark auch
wenn Sie Fragen zur gemeindebeteiligung
bislang nur Waage beantworten kann
wir wissen sicher dass es Geld geben
wird wir können das noch nicht
vertraglich fest regeln weil wir ja noch
nicht wissen wie groß die Anlage wird
wir haben hier für die Gemeinde eine
Möglichkeit auch Geld zu generieren und
mal so ganz nebenbei noch was für die
Welt zu tun das ist Harald Höppner nicht
konkret genug auch er engagiert sich in
der Bürgerinitiative in tempelfelde
wir haben hier noch ein ländlichen Raum
und wenn das hier überhand nimmt dann
haben wir den Industriegebiet wir wollen
den Solarpark an für sich gar nicht
abwenden wir wollen ihn nur in den
richtigen Rahmen bringen und das sind
Lage
Größe und Beteiligung der Gemeinde die
drei Dinge müssen stimmen ja seine
Forderungen nimmt er mit zur
Gemeinderatssitzung heute wird hier über
den Vorentwurf des Bebauungsplans
abgestimmt unsere Kameras sind wie auch
heute das Protestplakate nicht erwünscht
hinter verschlossenen Türen ausweichende
Antworten und feindselige Stimmung der
Solarpark hat aus ehemals guten Nachbarn
Gegner gemacht
wir waren per Du wir haben immer
miteinander kommuniziert und seit dem
Vorhaben haben die den Flucht nach vorne
es wird nur noch attackiert wenn ich mir
gesprochen der wird eigentlich nur noch
uns schlecht gemacht und das ist
eigentlich das was ich schade finde und
es lässt mit denen auch nicht mehr reden
und das hätte ich nicht gedacht
so weit soll es in Altlüdersdorf nicht
kommen hier ist man zwar gegen den
Solarpark aber vor allem für ein
harmonisches Miteinander
ein Kampf soll es niemals sein weil ein
Kampf bedeutet niemals eine Annäherung
wir wollen uns ja annähern wir wollen
niveauvoll miteinander diskutieren und
hier eine gemeinsame Lösung finden aber
viele der Bürger sehen das nicht die
sagen sie können sich das definitiv
nicht vorstellen mit diesem Solarpark
hier zu leben
sollte es dennoch dazu kommen müssen die
gute Verlierer sein
noch sind beide Projekte nicht in
trockenen Tüchern Zeit für Annäherung
bleibt auch in tempelfelde während die
Fronten bloß nicht so verhärtet
der Eindruck der sich mir immer mehr
aufdrängt ist es ist egal was an
Kompromiss
angeboten und durchgeführt wird es wird
nie genug sein
den Vorwurf weist die Bürgerinitiative
zurück und kontert das in Orten wie
ihrem die soziale Akzeptanz der
Energiewende verspielt wird
ich finde das Projekte um die 100
Millionen so ist ja die Größenordnung
von unserem Park gar nicht in
salopp ausgedrückt hobby-politiker Hände
gehören weil es sind Verträge die im
Zweifel tausend Seiten sind ja niemand
von uns ist Ingenieur niemand hatte von
uns studiert und deswegen gehören diese
Sachen nicht in Gemeindevertretung nicht
wenn sie nicht sozusagen flankiert von
Bundesgesetzen geschützt sind ein
regelvakuum das Investoren in die Hände
spielt aber zahlreiche Dörfer spaltet
die Bundesregierung will das Ausbautempo
von Wind und Solarkraft in Deutschland
verdreifachen derweil fühlen sich viele
Brandenburger schon von der aktuellen
Geschwindigkeit überrumpelt